hey what's going on everybody today I'm
going to continue breaking down some of
this new plot leak that is floating
around out there and see what seems
likely to happen during season 7 episode
2 and also at the end of this video I'm
going to be announcing the winner of the
game of Thrones blu-ray giveaway I'm
actually announcing it a day early
because I'm not sure if I'm going to be
uploading anything on Sunday so I would
rather do it early than late and if you
are new to this channel don't worry
because you can still win something
because I'm going to do several
giveaways in January all you need to do
is subscribe to this channel and like
this video for a chance to win and I'll
go into more details about this at the
end of this video but for now I want to
get started season 7 episode 2 States
John receives a message from Tyrion
asking all the Lords of the north to go
to Dragonstone to swear fealty to Queen
Daenerys John and Davos decide to go
because Tyrion mention she has dragons
and dragon stone has dragon glass now if
you have been up to date on all the
leaks then you probably already know
that this is going to happen I'm not
sure if Tyrion or Daenerys someone
everyone the dragon stone to bend the
knee or not but there had been hundreds
of leaked photos from the set of a beach
that is going to stand in his dragon
stone next season and in these photos we
see John Davos Tyrion and Daenerys
together in several of them so I think
this part of the leak is definitely
going to happen
and I think Tyrion probably would be the
one to send a message to everyone since
he is the hand of the Queen more than
likely his daily duties would be to take
care of that sort of stuff but there was
something mentioned in here that I
thought was kind of funny it says John
and Davos decided to go to Dragonstone
because Tyrion mentioned she has dragons
now something tells me that if Tyrion
mentions dragons in these letters that
summon all the lords it isn't going to
be because he is saying hey come check
out how cool these dragons are I think
it's probably going to be more along the
lines of come the dragon stone and bend
the knee or we will incinerate your
entire family with our flying
fire-breathing dinosaurs
plus there is dragon glass there but
John and Davos are going to be the only
ones probably asking about it
considering no one else even believes in
the others beyond the wall
so it would be wise of Davos and John to
go get some before all hell breaks loose
plus Davos spent a good bit of time on
Dragonstone with Stannis so he probably
knows just where to get it
but next it says John leaves Sansa in
control of the north and he says goodbye
to ghost John and Davos along with some
northern men head to white Harbor
now I actually talked about this scene
before in one of my other videos I think
this is pretty obvious if you know John
is going to be leaving Winterfell I
think Sansa would be the next one in
charge of John left and some people even
say she has a better claim to the land
anyway even though he was named king of
the north but out of all the leaked
photos from the set of Dragonstone I
haven't seen sands in any of them so I
assume this is true and she does stay
behind in Winterfell but personally I
just hope that John leaves some good men
behind to protect her as well
like Poorman because I'm concerned that
once John leaves
Littlefinger's going to start plotting
his takeover and brainwashing Sansa
turning her against people I hope if
John would leave tormund behind he he
wouldn't put up with that [ __ ] and saans
even told John only a fool would trust
Littlefinger so hopefully when John
leaves he goes to Poorman and tells him
to keep an eye on that little slimy
prick and not to let him get too close
to his sister Plus Brienne should be
coming back - and she's not going to put
up with any of that [ __ ] either so I
think Sansa would be in good hands while
John is gone plus ghost is there who
would definitely protect her against an
attack but I think it's obvious and
unfortunate why they chose to leave
ghost behind and I think it's all
because of the budget if it were up to
me ghost would be by John side at all
times
the Starks in their dire wolves should
be an extension of each other not always
left on the sidelines or back at home
but I'm not going to rain about this
most of you know how I feel about this
and most of you feel the same way now it
says you're on ambushes llores fleet and
after a few minutes of battle yara saves
Theon's life however she is capped
certain now I have spoke about this
before also mostly in the spoiler video
I made when these photos first started
to come out of your on Dragon Yara
through the streets of King's Landing
there is a very good chance this happens
in episode 2 because in these photos you
can also see the director Marc mulatto
who is going to be directing episodes 2
and 3 so I could easily see this battle
taking place at the beginning of the
episode then at some point later in the
episode he could drag them through the
streets now there could be a time issue
of course if this battle happens way out
at sea but it wouldn't be the first time
characters travel a great distance in a
little amount of time and it is likely
that you're a would save Fiona at this
point she is more of the protector
between the two and I could see her
whisking herself to save him knowing he
couldn't handle being a prisoner again
you're as tough as nails and I think she
could handle it mentally obviously way
more than Theon can right now at least
until he gets his confidence back
Theon wasn't in any of the photos with
Euron in King's Landing so I'm just
going to assume he wasn't captured with
the other girls now
Tyrion convinces Dany not to use her
dragons to take King's Landing because
most of the people who would die would
be innocent now this does sound like a
good idea at first but Daenerys isn't
going to be able to hold them back
forever Cersei will never surrender the
throne and Dany is going to be forced to
use them at some point we already saw in
brains vision that they will fly over
King's Landing and we also saw in bran
in Danny's vision that the Great Hall
where the iron throne is kept gets
completely destroyed especially the roof
by what looks like would have been
dragons burning through the city so
Tyrion could say this to her now but
eventually the Dragons will need to be
used to finally stop this psycho named
Cersei but that's just my opinion
Jaime arrives at horn Hill and he
convinces randyll Tarly to bend the knee
and Jaime promises to let house Tarly
become the new warden of the south the
only thing I can really
about this is we know from spoilers that
at some point next season Jamie and
randyll Tarly will join teams and fight
alongside each other which is a complete
turn of events
Randall Tarly was supporting the Tyrells
who are now enemies are the Lannisters
but something must happen that gets
randyll Tarly to go against them and
join forces with the Lannisters and
photos were leaked that showed the
Lannisters and tarly's
shoulder-to-shoulder preparing for
battle so I could see a conversation
something like this taking place I'm
pretty sure this battle is supposed to
take place during Episode four according
to the reports not the leaked plot but
it was an actual report that came out so
if this battle does happen during
Episode four then it would make sense
that Jamie meets with Randall beforehand
and come up with some sort of plan in
Episode two so for now I'm not going to
rule this out Jorah goes to the Citadel
and find Sam
Sam finds out that dragonglass is the
cure for greyscale
now how pissed do you think Stannis
would be if he found this out
Stannis spent all that money and he got
all those maesters to find a cure and
there's a chance that the island Stannis
was living on was made out of a [ __ ]
that could have saved his daughter
I found this part of the plot leaked to
be very interesting though but I don't
know if I believe this part to be true
I wonder how dragonglass would be the
cure I wonder if Sam would have to stab
Jorah through the heart with it just
like what happened to the night's king
and uncle Benjen or do you think Jorah
has to crush it up and snort it but on
the other hand I wouldn't be surprised
if dragonglass ended up being the Cure
because damn near everything to do with
the Dragons is magical and can do so
many different things so I'm not going
to say this is ridiculous just yet Sam
is at the Citadel and he is hungry for
answers so I wouldn't be shocked if he
was the one to figure this out John and
Davos arrived at white Harbor and takes
ships to Dragonstone now we already know
this from all the set photos so let's
move right along
brain and mirror leave Castle black on
horseback and head to Winterfell there
have been a few photos of brain Amira
one set with a bunch of the other cast
members it doesn't necessarily mean they
were all filming scenes together but I
think it will be some scenes of brain at
Winterfell for sure I don't think he's
going to stay at Castle black forever
and with all the information he has been
downloading from the weirwood search
engine he's going to need to get this
information to the right person plus he
probably does want to see his family
last time he saw some of them he was
just a little boy but personally I'm
very anxious to see what brain finds out
next I hope we get a shitload of
flashback scenes or even scenes from the
future I think brain can have one of the
most interesting storylines next season
when he continues to find out what the
hell's going on and what the hell's
going to happen
I think bran is going to end up being
one of the most important characters in
the entire story alright now this part
was a little controversial and this is
when Arya attacks Melisandre however
before Arya kills mother Sondra she
tells area that Gendry is still alive
now I got a lot of questions about this
part people seem to be confused about
how this scene will end at the end of
the leak Melisandre --zz name wasn't on
the death list so that could mean she
didn't die but it says Melisandre only
says this before she is killed so she
may have died anyway but to be honest I
cannot give you the answer because I
don't know if the death list at the end
was screwed up or not and if Melisandre
was meant to be on it and the person
just forgot to put her name
personally Arya should kill her
the only reason why Jen's relived was
because Davos helped him escape
Melisandre's intentions were to kill him
so I wouldn't blame Oreo for taking her
out even if she does tell her Gendry get
away but what I'm wondering is do you
think Melisandre would know that Arya
and Jon are related because if I were
Melisandre I'd be telling her hey I
brought your brother back to life you
know will you spare my life for doing
that
I think Oreo would definitely consider
it then but I doubt she could trust her
and already made a video about Aria
crossing paths with Melisandre but I
still haven't decided myself whether or
not Oreo will still kill her and that's
only because Aria has taken a name off
of her list before and if Aria would
find out ginjury didn't die and she'd
also find out that Melisandre did bring
John back then I think Aria would
actually spare her life
but if Aria doesn't learn of these
things then Melisandre is dead for sure
but that's just my opinion but speaking
again Juri the next part says he sneaks
past some gold cloaks and steals
Robert's Warhammer and Cersei finds out
the Warhammer was stolen it doesn't care
however she finds out she is pregnant
after Qyburn examines her now there was
photos again three on the beach swinging
a war hammer so this may be how he
actually gets it I know the photo is
very hard to make out who the person
actually is but I believe at the begin
tree and another photos where he doesn't
have the hammer it is actually easier to
make out who this person may be so I
think there is a good chance ginjury did
steal his father's Warhammer but Gendry
can also make his own weapons so I think
he could have made this one himself
after Melisandre told Kendrick that his
father was Robert Baratheon and after
Gendry escaped he may have thought to
make one just like his father used to
have so I'm not too sure how he comes
into possession of the hammer actually
but I could picture Cersei not giving a
[ __ ] about it being gone we know she
didn't love Robert and she wanted him
dead so why would she care about some
dumb hammer in her eyes I wasn't sure
what point there you know was to reveal
that Cersei was pregnant again and
that's the next part but thanks to you
guys you figured it must have to do with
the prophecy so I'm just gonna leave it
at that and lastly the Tyrell forces
surrender the episode ends with Lady
Alana telling Jaime that she poisoned
Joffrey she then kills herself with
poison now I have yet to see any
evidence of this yet I do know from
spoiler photos that the Lannister in the
Tyrells will battle each other so there
is a chance that when Jaime
Saxe Highgarden wins and they stormed
the castle there could be a scene with
him and Lady Olenna but personally I
wish she would go out differently Lady
Olenna is a tough old bird
so I'd hate to see her just kill herself
I wish she'd be able to escape somehow
but again that's just my opinion I just
wouldn't want to see her you know commit
suicide I'd rather her go out and I'm a
much more glorious way than that but
overall I could see a lot of this [ __ ]
taking place next season most of this
stuff was already in the original leak
and most I have speculated on before as
the set photos came out so I am leaning
towards most of this happening I just
can't guarantee you which episodes is
going to happen in but you can comment
below and we can go over it and try to
figure out some better answers for their
stuff but now it's time to announce the
winner of the game of Thrones blu-ray
giveaway but let me say this first if
you did not win the blu-ray do not
unsubscribe because I have two other
things I'm giving away next and if you
are new here just subscribe and like
this video for your chance to win it to
the next giveaway will be this game of
Thrones t-shirt which I will let you get
it in your size 2 and the other thing
I'm adding to the next giveaway is going
to be this the first game of Thrones
book in the series so the next giveaway
which I will announce the winner of next
weekend will have two prizes this
t-shirt and this book both brand new so
stick around for that if you want it now
the winner of the blu-ray is and this
was randomly selected the winner is
night-fighter
so congratulations my friend just
message me your address and what season
you want and I will send that right away
and thank you to everyone who
participated and good luck in the next
giveaway bye guys and also have a good
New Year and thank you for showing your
love hopefully you guys have a good
night just don't do anything too crazy
don't drink and drive see you guys later
bye